you've got or there's a second point
there's a queue as well you've got these
two points on this parabola M is the
midpoint of the cord PQ so we all need
to have this drawing so we can get an
idea of what's going on so that's where
and this it's the midpoint yeah go ahead
it's called draw it because I'm talking
through it still it took me a little
time to get there T is the point of
intersection of the tangents at P and Q
yeah yeah okay well let's see how we go
right I may have to move people I don't
know I'll like twist it around a little
bit okay so I don't make it I'll make it
yeah just barely because that's anyway
so there's my tangent at P and I should
have read the whole question first for
no that would have been helpful ah here
is the tangent at Q I'm gonna make it
it'll be alright okay so they say T is
the point of intersection of these two
tangents so that's looking okay
now what do we do with all these things
together show that the tangent at P has
the equation and this is equation we've
derived before but as I pointed out you
do need to know how to prove it okay so
if they've said prove okay I'm actually
to go one step extra we know because
we've worked with these things that the
definition of P the definition of the
parameter the reason we choose it as the
parameter is it's the gradient at that
point that's why it's so powerful and so
useful
however if they've said prove then
actually the burden is on us to actually
show that it is the gradient it's not
hard if y is equal to x squared on for a
I've just changed the subject
okay the derivative dy/dx is very easy
to work out it's just X on that's a bad
X its X on to a right well at P then X
is 2 AP right at
the derivative will be equal to two AP
on to a so there there it is right so it
would be nice to be able to say hey it's
the gradient but if you have to prove it
it's like super easy so that's not hot
okay I know the gradient I know the
point that it goes through so this if I
want to find out it's just point grading
form okay so let's do that
therefore the tangent at P so as I've
said a few times before
don't just launch into an equation tell
me what this equation is the tangent at
P will be Y - yep there's my y1 equals M
which is which is P the gradient outside
of X minus x1 are you happy with that
I will just expand so that I can collect
some like terms - 2 AP squared have a
look at the form that they've given it
to you in what should I do
on the next line yeah the reason I put
this out is because in parametric's you
guys might remember that not all of the
equations of lines like that the nice
the nice neat ones they're not all in
like this is slope intercept form like
think about the quarter of contact 1 X X
naught to a blah blah that's not any
form at all it's like something random
form so you've got to know where it's
going so that you know how to simplify
so Part A is done I'm just gonna say
hence at Q because they also ask you for
that change n @q y will be QX - a Q
squared for all the same reasons okay I
suppose I could have said similarly plop
it show that M has coordinates data okay
I'm not even gonna do that one with you
because um we've got two coordinates we
know how to find a midpoint so in fact
if you have a look at it carefully you
can see all they're doing is averaging
the coordinates that have been provided
so that's fine
Part C show that T has the coordinates a
P plus Q and a P Q yeah
yeah fantastic so we just went through
the effort of finding out these two
equations so I'm going to solve this
sound seriously okay I am also going to
point out while we're looking at this
okay there's something interesting in
here which is that if you have a look
down here see how in the y-coordinate
you've got this a PQ business remember a
is just the focal length so on a
parabola that length is going to stay
put it's a it's a single value doesn't
change right our P and Q can change but
if you recall if you have say for
example a focal coin if you've got a
focal chord what you end up finding is
that p and q when you multiply them
together you get negative one now that
means two important things which often
get asked firstly P and Q their
gradients aren't there when you multiply
the gradients of two things what does
that mean and when you get negative one
these they're at right angles okay so if
you've got a focal chord if this chord
passed through the focus then these two
tangents will be at right angles it's
it's frequently asked for you to prove
that result and this is how you do it
you show PQ is negative one and then you
don't but then the the secondly if they
want to make the question a little bit
harder is if peak is negative one
then down here this will just be - hey
do you agree but on on this parabola if
the y coordinate is minus a that's an
important line for this parabola
it's the directrix right so sometimes
they will ask you to prove show that if
such as such is a focal chord then the
point of intersection of the tangents is
always on the directrix and this is what
they're talking about you prove that
this is the case and then you can pop it
into here take oh cool I have the
equation of the directrix okay so that's
not the question you asked or it's not
the question that they've asked but this
so frequently comes up that I need to
point it out now yeah yeah bingo it's a
very common because it's such a cool
sort of property
that's why they like to prove it a lot
okay well this is an interesting show
that mt mt is parallel to the axis of
the parabola well I'm not going to draw
my n to you because it's not powerful
but you can use your imagination okay
how we do this if I am required to prove
that MT is parallel okay when we usually
talk about lines being parallel we
appeal to gradient there is a teeny
teeny problem with that in this case
Eric okay so in this case I'm gonna be
in some trouble if I try and calculate
the gradient because I wouldn't actually
say the gradients vertical I would say
the gradient is undefined because the
line is vertical yeah
a gradient is a number so a number can't
I mean you know what is it that's very
cool and this horizontal hey how does
that mean okay so the gradient is
undefined so I cannot evaluate this but
if I do know that the axis is in this
case vertical that means the empty
should be vertical which means that this
x-coordinate should be the same as this
x-coordinate have a look I think we just
proved that didn't we you see in Part B
in Part C you can see the coordinates
they're the same I'm done okay but you
just need to state it really the very
last question find the coordinates of
the midpoint and okay fine just use your
imagination right so n is somewhere
around here and show sure that it lies
on the parabola okay there we go
should have read the whole question all
right so so how do I do this how do I do
this well MT is a vertical line correct
so therefore how do I what's what's a
nice easy way to just find that midpoint
there yeah because the x coordinates are
gonna be the same so n will have this
as its x-coordinate because the ends
have the same exponent then Y will be
well let's have a look it's a bit messy
algebraically I've got a PQ down here
and then I've got a half a squared is
that right no a and it's the piece
that's P and Q that's good P squared
plus Q squared up there so I'm going to
have to arrange the two things out so
the average of them is 1/2 a P squared
plus Q squared plus plus yep
the other thing yeah it does in fact do
you see it because once you get this out
you will get your result here I'm just
going to call it out y1 because it
should be on the parabola right you're
going to put that in once you have such
corner how do you prove that something
is on the parabola yeah if I substitute
this into the original equation it ought
to satisfy that equation and hence
proven okay does that make sense